[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous
présente le club des
territoires et avec nous comme tous les
lundis trard bonjour r merci d'être avec
nous directeur adjoint de la rédaction
du Figaro et Mathieu souer avec nous
bonjour Mathie souer essiste expert
associé à la Fondation Jean jores
coauteur de 2022 la flambée populiste on
voit le livre sécher plomb on va parler
avec vous du conflit entre Israël et le
Hamas quelle conséquence en France alors
que Gérald harmanin annonce que près de
200 actes antisémites ont été recensés
depuis samedi dernier il y a-t-il un
lien entre ce conflit et l'attaque
terroriste à haras au cours de laquelle
le prof de français Dominique Bernard a
été tué Gérald harmanin fait le lien
ellisabeth Bor ne n'exclut pas on va en
parler une attaque qui est intervenue
alors qu'aujourd'hui marque les 3 ans de
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty et demain
Alex sa sœur est auditionnée au Sénat
effectivement Michel Paty sera
auditionné par la commission d'enquête
du Sénat sur les menaces qui pèsent
contre les enseignants voilà pour le
programme on passe tout de suite à ce
[Musique]
club et on va commencer en parlant de ce
qui s'est passé vendredi à aras et
aujourd'hui c'est un retour en classe
sous le signe de l'hommage à Dominique
Bernard professeur de français victime
du terrorisme islamiste à 14h une minute
de silence sera observée Gabriel Atal
s'est montré très ferme il ne toléra
aucune contestation durant cet hommage
flur sauvage après les frroids l'hommage
dimanche la place centrale d'aras était
noire de monde pour commémorer la
mémoire de Dominique Bernard poignardé à
mort vendredi par un ancien élève
radicalisé l'attentat a provoqué une
onde de choc alors que la France
commémore ce lundi l'assassinat il y a 3
ans de Samuel pati décapité pour avoir
montré des caricatures de Mahomet en
classe une minute de silence est prévue
à 14
dans tous les établissements scolaires
en hommage aux victimes d'attentat
contre l'école je vais être très clair
et très ferme je ne tolérerai aucune
contestation aucune provocation à
l'occasion de cet endommage le ministre
de l'éducation nationale a annoncé le
déploiement de 1000 personnels de
sécurité dans les établissements
scolaires en déplacement dans son fief
des nin beumont Marine Le Pen a dénoncé
les manquements du ministre de
l'Intérieur Géral Darmanin selon la
présidente du Group Ren à l'Assemblée
nationale le jeune Russe auteur de
l'attaque qui éta suivi depuis peu par
les services de renseignement aurait dû
être expulsé à quelle occasion un
ministre doit-il démissionner si ce
n'est lorsque il est confronté à une
chaîne de défaillance tellement longue
tellement
grave qu'elle a permis un épouvantable
drame supplémentaire selon le député de
la France insoumise François Ruffin
l'auteur de l'attaque n'avait plus rien
à faire en France fam devait plus être
en France pour moi là ce que ce qu'on a
sous les yeux c'est le haut du spectre
du fichier de la radicalisation outre
l'expulsion vers la Russie pour
radicalisation du père de l'assaillant
le frère de l'auteur de l'attaque à
haras a été condamné à 5 ans de prison
pour un projet d'attentat visant
l'Élysée et on va parler de tous ces
sujets d'abord rive 14h aujourd'hui
l'hommage à Dominique Bernard ce
professeur de français tué Gabriel LAL
l'a dit hier il sera très ferme il Toa
aucune contestation aucune provocation
elles sont à redouter oui bah on avait
vu qu'avec les hommages qui avaient été
rendus après Samuel Patti il y avait eu
certaines dans certaines classes mais
c'était très minoritaire pareil après le
Bataclan je crois il y avait eu pas mal
de euh enfin il y avait eu quelques cas
comme ça alors évidemment qui soit
intraitable ça paraît logique après bon
qu'est-ce que faire euh alors il y a un
dispositif législatif euh exclure
temporairement l'intéresser de son
établissement procéder à des poursuites
judiciaires il y a tout un arsenal dit
sais une systématique du procureur voilà
il faut que bon ben d'abord il faut que
ça lui soit sinu allé parce que il faut
que la l'école aussi le le monde
éducatif sorte de de cette chapte de
plomb qui consiste à à ne pas faire de
bruit à ne pas faire de vagues vous
savez le pas de vaguisme et bien là il
va falloir maintenant que les
enseignants et le corps éducatif euh
parle et arrête de jouer à la grande
muette d'une certaine façon ouais Mathie
souer ce qui s'est passé 3 ans quasiment
jour pour jour après l'assassinat de
Samuel pati ça montre que l'école aour
aujourd'hui est une cible très forte
pour les terroristes islamies alors oui
manifestement ce qu'a dit Gabriel Atal
traduit aussi quand même la volonté que
nous ayons une forme de d'union
nationale relativement irréprochable car
effectivement il y a quand même face à
des événements de cet ordre une volonté
d'union nationale alors ce qui frappe
puisque en fait aujourd'hui ce ce triste
3e anniversaire ce qui frappe évidemment
c'est le sentiment de déjà vu c'estd que
c'était un c'était un cas isolé en
réalité Samuel paatti l'horreur de ce
qui était arrivé à Samuel Patti
traduisait le fait queon était face à un
acte de folie et un acte isolé à partir
du moment où il y a une répétition c'est
plus un acte isolé et si ça se'est répét
une fois ça peut se répéter plusieurs
fois je dirais qu'il a il y a par
ailleurs même une petite nouveauté par
rapport à Samel paatti c'était tout à
fait horrible Samel paatti ça faisait
suite ce qui c'était le drame faisait
suite à une polémique autour de ce qui
s'était passé en cours de caricature et
cetera là on a un gamin ancien élève de
ce de ce lycée qui est retourné dans son
lycée pour se faire un prof d'histoire
c'est c'est c'est ça il y a il cherchait
personne spécifiquement manifestement
enfin encore une fois il y aura une
enquête mais là il voulait se faire un
prof d'histoire donc c'est c'est l'école
qui évidemment désormais prise pour
cible c'est l'école qui notre schéma de
représentation collective est un
sanctuaire un lieu qui protège devient
en réalité en tant que tel un lieu
exposé et au-delà de l'école de ce lieu
effectivement d'instruction et et c'est
c'est un prof d'histoire ce sont les
profs d'histoire la communauté des profs
d'histoire qui évé c'est ceux qui
précisément porte non seulement une
vision nationale mais derrière des cours
d'instruction civiques voilà et donc il
y a quelque chose de tout à fait
symbolique évidemment à travers le le
profil qui était ciblé et et ce que vous
dites c'est ce que rappelle Emmanuel
Macron ce matin qui dit l'école restera
un sanctuaire un rempart contre
l'obscurantisme elle est encore
aujourd'hui l'école ce sanctuaire bah
oui il faut le faut le il faut l'espérer
il faut le souhaiter il faut tout faire
pour ce qui est sûr si vous voulez et on
a tous des expériences dans ce sens-là
c'est que les professeurs d'histoire ont
souvent du mal à aborder quelques
chapitres de de l'histoire hein euh dans
certains lycées mais pas uniquement dans
des lycées de zone sensible des grands
lycées de centreville enseigner le
conflit
israël-palestinien c'est quasiment
impossible hein euh enseigner la Choa
c'est compliqué donc tout ça
effectivement c'est c'est des choses qui
doivent être mis sur la table à mon avis
il faut absolument
que et bien l'éducation recouvre son
exercice d'autorité et que cette
autorité soit exercée et que on ne se
laisse pas marcher sur les pieds et
intimidé
par certains groupes certains élèves il
faut absolument que la France là-dessus
reste droite debout et affirme ses ses
valeurs et affirme ça ça sa vision je
dirais de l'homme et et de l'histoire la
Fondation jeanores a documenté dans un
nombre d'enquêtes avec l'ipope en
particulier la montée effectivement de
ces de ces phénomènes d'autocensure chez
lesprs d'histoire
géo je pense en particulier à des
travaux de de Jérôme Fourquet qui
démontre en quelques années à cause
précisément de l'affaire Samuel paatti
la proportion de profs qui disent
s'autocensurer en particulier dans
l'enseignement du conflit
israëlo-palestinien est passé d'un/4 à
un/ers alors je sais pas ce que ce
chiffre veut dire mais il veut bien dire
que la liberté de l'enseignement elle
n'est pas totalement garantie al encore
une fois l'autocensure dans une société
comme la nôtre on la pratique au
quotidien et heureusement ça nous évite
de dire tout ce qu'on pense tout le
temps et avec n'importe qui donc ça nous
évite souvent de dire des bêtises
néanmoins ça pose évidemment problème et
derrière le sentiment de déjà vu que
j'évoquais il y a pour le coup un
sentiment d'impuissance et c'est ça qui
fait que l'école n'apparaît plus comme
un sanctuaire elle l' évidemment
symboliquement mais elle ne l'est plus
physiquement je crois que tous les
lycéens et tout le corps enseignant de
d'aras l'a bien ressenti lundi mais on
l'a tous collectivement ressenti ce
sentiment d'impuissance et donc la
question question précisément va être de
dire comment est-ce qu'on lutte contre
ce sentiment d'impuissance il y a je
pense encore à une enquête que la
Fondation gen a produitite il y a une
dizaine de jours sa grande enquête
annuelle sur les fractures françaises il
y a aujourd'hui dans la société
française des sentiments qui sont très
profonds très puissants et qu'une
séquence comme celle-ci ne va faire
qu'envenimer que conforter le fait que
vous avez aujourd'hui quasiment la
moitié de la population française qui se
dit en colère vous avez les 2 tiers de
la population française qui disent il y
a trop d'étrangers chez nous il y a trop
d'étrangers chez nous parce que que on
voit bien qu'on est tenté de lier la
question sécuritaire et la question
migratoire il y a trop d'étrangers chez
nous et ils ne font pas assez d'efforts
pour s'intégrer le fait que il y a une
demande d'ordre accru on l'a vu au mois
de juillet avec les ce qu'on a appelé
les émeutes urbaines la question était
moins une question sociale aux yeux
d'une majorité de l'opinion qui une
question sécuritaire et donc évidemment
dès qu'un phénomène comme comme comme
ceci se produit ça amplifie ce type de
croyance ce type de conviction et on
disait ce cette attaque elle est arrivée
quasiment 3 g jour pour jour après
l'assassinat de Samuel Patis et
aujourd'hui ce triste anniversaire Alex
et demain une commission d'enquête au
Sénat va auditionner sa sœur pour faire
la lumière sur l'assassinat de Samuel
paatti oui ce sera demain à 15h Michel
pay est entendu par la commission
d'enquête du Sénat sur les menaces et
agressions contre les enseignants une
commission d'enquête que la sœur de
Samuel Patti avait elle-même demandé au
sénateurs c'était en mai dernier dans
une lettre ouverte à Gérard Larcher le
président du Sénat je la cite je
sollicite auprès de votre chambre la
possibilité de demander des comptes aux
personnes responsables de la mauvaise
gestion du traitement erroné de la
menace pesant sur mon frère et du défaut
de prévoyance qui en a découlé facteurs
qui sont à l'origine de sa mort quelques
semaines plus tard et bien les sénateurs
créaient cette commission d'enquête avec
plusieurs objectifs on va écouter à
l'époque C en joint le président du
groupe les républicains au Sénat
brenorotillon l'objectif c'est
d'éclairer les conditions dans
lesquelles euh les services de
l'éducation nationale les services de
sécurité ont protégé ou non euh Sam
près de 80 % des enseignants déclarent
que le ministère leur propre ministère
n'a pas tiré les leçons de la
décapitation de Samuel Patti et cette
demande de commission d'enquête de la
part de Michael paaty elle fait suite à
un livre d'investigation du journaliste
Stéphane Simon qui a enquêtaé sur les 11
derniers jours vécus par Samuel pati
avant son assassinat et Stéphane Simon
était sur notre plateau vendredi dernier
Orian et il il dénonçait et bien la
faillite de l'État la faillite des
service de renseignement dans la
protection de l'enseignant qui a été
menacé on écoute on peut prévoir que
Samuel paatti est menacé et là il y a
une faille c'est que normalement vous
avez plusieurs possibilités pour
protéger un professeur ou une
personnalité menacée il suffisait d'un
coup de fil de la DGSI d'un agent de la
DGSI pour dire à Samuel Patti n'allez
plus en cours ne venez plus à l'école on
n'est pas sûr de pouvoir assurer votre
sécurité alors avant l'audition de
Michel paatti demain les sénateurs de la
commission d'enquête ont déjà auditionné
papendia l'ancien ministre de
l'éducation nationale et la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur Sylvi r taillot
des sénateurs qui ont jusqu'à la fin de
l'année pour conclure leurs travaux
ouais et sur l'assassinat de Samuel pati
comme dans ce qui s'est passé à ras il a
la question des services de
renseignement le le tueur d'aras il
était suivi par les services de
renseignement il avait été auditionné la
veille Gérald hermanant dit qu'il y a
pas eu de
faille oui non mais c'est toujours le
même problème si vous voulez c'est que
pour arrêter ou pour interpeller
quelqu'un il il faut qu'il ait
manifestation d'un acte délctueux
ou d'avoir proféré des propos ce qui
était pas le cas apparemment on sent les
services de renseignement apparemment
avaient des beaucoup de questions sur
cette sur ce jeune homme mais il leur
manquait quelque chose pour pour
l'appréhender je pense que la faille
elle est pas là arrêtons de dire mais
arrêtons de dire d'abord il y a il y a
deux types de de d'individus qui passent
à l'acte vous avez des individus qui
sont nés en France
euh qui se radicalisent en France et
puis vous avez des individus qui sont
qui viennent de l'étranger et qui se
radicalise soit à l'étranger soit en
France lui c'est un peu des deux puisque
il est arrivé en France il avait 6 ans
mais arrêtons de dire qu'il y a pas
toujours euh de de laisser côté
l'immigration il y a eu une faille en
2014 en 2014 la France a failli en 2014
en plus vous avez vu son père a été
renvoyé a été pulsé de France pour
radicalisation en 2014 cette famille
n'aurait aurait pu quitter le territoire
français elle n'a pas quitté le
territoire français pour une raison qui
paraît qui qui
aujourd'hui va sans doute être remise en
question c'est que bah il y avait des
enfants scolarisés c'est la
jurisprudence leonarda en fait il y
avait eu leonarda peu de temps avant
et c'est la circulaire Vals voilà et
puis maintenant aussi c'est ai cette
disposition de Nicolas Sarkozi qui fait
que quand vous êtes arrivé sur le
territoire avant l'âge de 13 ans et bien
on peut pas sauf cas tout à fait
exceptionnel on peut pas vous expulser
donc il a il y a quand même si vous
voulez eu des failles de de de l'État
français mais c'est des failles ou c'est
il faut revoir notre logiciel il faut
revoir la l vous savez on parle souvent
d'Israël moi je conis bon Israël qui est
en but aux attentats en permanence mais
depuis 70 ans en permanence revoit sa
législation sur la sécurité mais
régulièrement alors arrêtons de dire que
il faut ça sert à rien d'empiler oui le
le principal c'est d'appliquer et
d'exécuter ce qu'on a pas fait parce que
la France n'a pas fait en 2014 mais
c'est c'est manifeste mais il faut aussi
ajuster notre législation et la
législation semble-t-il euh bah permet
justement euh grâce à Nicolas Sarkozi
de de ne pas éloigner quelqu'un qui a
qui est arrivé en France avant l'âge de
13 ans et et d'où la loi immigration et
est-ce que on va vers un durcissement
Mathieu Soukar Emmanuel Macron ce matin
il demande au au préfet de revoir au
pagneopin le fichier des personnes
radicalisées Gérald amamanin dit qu'il
faut expulser les fichiers S pour
radicalisation étranger est-ce qu' on va
vers une politique de durcissement alors
il y a le durcissement pour envoyer un
signal à l'opinion c'est dire que là
pour le coup alors on peut le dire de
façon un peu triviale c'est de la come
mais en même temps les messages qu'on
envoie sont toujours importants et puis
il y a le durcissement pour gagner
éventuellement en efficacité je parlais
tout à l'heure du sentiment de déjà vu
et du sentiment qui derrière en
filigrane existait qui est un sentiment
d'impuissance je ne sais pas si on peut
dire que parce qu'il y a sentiment de
déjà vu et sentiment d'impuissance il y
a réellement défillances en tout cas on
a vu que ces affaires-là étaient
éminemment complexes on a reparlé à
l'occasion des des événements de du du
du conflit israelllo-palestinien la
semaine dernière précisément de la
défaillance des services de
renseignement israélien qui renvoyait à
la défaillance des services de
renseignement américains au moment du 11
septembre on voit que même les
puissances les plus organisées les mieux
dotées et qui revoient très
régulièrement leur législation ne sont
pas infaillibles et au contraire on voit
bien que on a malgré tout des forces de
l'ordre et des services de renseignement
qui ont plutôt bien fait voir très bien
fait leur boulot je ne conteste pas que
à la fin il y a précisément une issue
dramatique mais ont plutôt bien fait
leur boulot le gars en question avait
déjà été identifié il était plus
qu'identifié il était surveillé et en
plus de ça il avait été contrôlé la
veille et il y aura une enquête qui dira
précisément comment les choses se sont
passées mais personne n'avait puis
identifier le la moindre trace le
moindre indice de passage à l'acte donc
c'est pas si mal ensuite le risque zéro
on le sait n'existe pas existe d'autant
moins que nous vivons dans une société
où contrairement à ce qu'on a vécu
pendant des années et des années même
des décennies où des événements
internationaux pouvait s'inviter sur le
sol national on a connu un certain
nombre d'attentats en France qui étaient
liés à une actualité au Proche-Orient au
Liban en Syrie en Algérie et cetera tout
ça on l'a vécu on l'a vécu parce que
précisément ces réseaux terroristes
étaient organisés aujourd'hui avec la
mondialisation de l'actualité et de
l'information et les réseaux sociaux je
dirais que n'importe quel individu
n'importe quel gus sur notre sol peut
devenir un terroriste en puissance et y
compris un gamin qui retourne dans son
lycée alors je ne sais pas s'il y a eu
une défaillance en 2014 encore une fois
le terroriste dont on parle celui qui a
commis cet acte terrible vendredi avait
5 ou 6 ans à l'époque donc à quoi ça
rime de considérer que parce que sa
famille n'a pas été expulsée il y a 10
ou 15 ans ce gaminlà allait devenir un
terroriste qui allait nous saisi
aujourd'hui c'est c'est tout à fait
compliqué et je dirais juste une
dernière chose qui devait être qui était
expulsable je dirais certes mais enfin
encore une fois le problème c'est pas sa
famille le problème aujourd'hui c'est
lui lui il avait 12 ans il avait 12 ans
pardon bah encore une fois un gamin de
12 ans reste un gamin de 12 ans donc les
les choses sont suffisamment complexes
pour se méfier des réponses ou des
propos qui y compris chez nous en ce
moment en fait sont un peu àant
porte-pièce sont un peu simpl sont un
peu simpliste et alimente des polémiques
dont on devrait au contraire se passer
tant le sens de la nuance pareil sur ces
sujets Absolum indispensable et vous
parliez Mathieu souer du conflit entre
Israël et le Hamas Gérald armanin a tenu
une conférence de presse samedi lui
n'exclut pas le lien entre ce conflit au
Proche-Orient et le passage à l'acte à
haras son
l'écoute certain en revanche que une
atmosphère comme dirait les chercheurs
une atmosphère de djihadisme de passage
à l'acte est évident depuis C dernier je
me suis moême exprimé plusieurs fois
avant l'attentat
d'aras une certaine réjouissance a lieu
parmi les cibles que nous suivons de
l'islam radical et nous pensons comme
d'autres services de renseignement
occidentaux que ces images cette
apologie du terrorisme ces volonté très
clair de pouvoir avoir des actes
antisémites sous prétexte
d'antisciionisme permettent un passage à
l'acte plus facile Mathieu sou est-ce
qu'on est Gérald harmanin lui il fait le
lien est-ce qu'on est sur ce qu'on a
appelé une importation du conflit bah en
tout cas il y a eu effectivement la part
du Hamas en particulier un appel au
djihad vendredi enfin il y a une
porosité évidemment entre ce qui se
passe là-bas et ce qui se passe ici
c'est l'évidence même mais comme je
comme je le disais à l'instant encore
une fois je ne sais pas dans quelle
mesure pour de vrai ce jeune de 20 ans
était si politisé si fanatiser que cela
il y a une part de jeunesse totalement
paumée qui est capable par le biais des
réseaux sociaux de s'intéresser à des
causes et de commettre des actes
irréparables et en plus les réseaux
sociaux parlons de cette banalité mais
précisément entretiennent encourageent
une forme de mimétisme donc dès lors que
tout ça existe que tout ça est filmé on
l'a vu l'émotion qui nous saisit elle
est aussi liée aux images qui circulent
tout comme on a vécu en en juillet cette
bavure policière filmée en direct les
images là désormais elles ont une force
et un impact considérable sur l'opinion
qui est saisie elle-même saisie
d'effroids saisie de colère et cetera et
sur des gamins qui peuvent être tentés
encore une fois de de de jouer d'une
forme de mimétisme donc oui
l'importation elle existe parce
qu'encore une fois aujourd'hui le monde
de toute façon est une cage en vert tout
se voit tout se sait tout se montre la
mondialisation de l'information c'est
aussi une mondialisation des émotions et
des émotions positives comme des
émotions négatives il est là le risque
d'importation y alors il y a eu cette
attaque terroriste islamiste Gérald
armanan dit qu'il y a aussi près de 200
actes antisémites depuis le début de
l'attaque du Hamas ou mais on aa pas
attendu vous savez on n pas attendu ce
qui s'est passé au Proche Orient pour
qu'il y ait de l'antisémitisme en France
pour qu'il y ait des actes des des actes
comment terroristes comme on vient de le
vivre euh ce jeune homme qui s'est
radicalisé euh petit petit à petit il
serait peut-être passé à l'acte sans ce
contexte à ce moment-là on peut rappeler
on peut on peut rappeler aussi des 3 ans
de de de de Samuel paatti parce que
comme vous le savez son assassin a été
de Samuel pati a
été a été tué sur le coup
quasiment il serait peut-être passé à
l'acte en dehors de tout ça c'est ça qui
doit nous interroger beaucoup plus de
savoir si il y a un lien que le ministre
de l'Intérieur le fasse ce lien pourquoi
pas effectivement il y a un contexte il
y a une atmosphère qui est propice à ça
mais ce qui est important c'est de
savoir si cette ce jeune homme
euh comment il s'est radicalisé comment
il en est arrivé là c'est c'est ça qui
qui nous faut qu' nous faut qu' nous
faut connaître et c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas ce qui s'est passé la semaine
dernière dans les en Israël qui va qui
va qui va tout expliquer bien sûr que
nona mais est-ce qu'on est sur une
transformation du terrorisme une sorte
de terrorisme locoste entre gu avec des
jeunes qui se radicalisent tout seul qui
passent à l'acte avec un couteau qu'on
peut t avoir chez nous et qui du coup ne
sont pas détectables alors moi je nen
suis pas du tout spécialiste
effectivement des questions de
terrorisme mais c'est ce que disent ceux
qui s'intéressent et qui suivent en
particulier les trajectoires alors ce
sont soit des loups solitaires là en
l'occurrence il y avait quand même un
Terrero familial un peu complexe un peu
problématique mais encore une fois c'est
ce qui fait que ce gamalin en
particulier il était suivi il était
suivi alors ensuite précisément comme ce
type de profil se multiplie le risque
zéro n'existe pas on ne peut pas
surveiller on ne peut pas traquer et on
ne peut pas bloquer avant même que des
actes ne se commettent l'ensemble des
citoyens sur un territoire particulier
rappelons toutefois quand même que le
nombre d'attentats déjoués dépasse de
très loin le nombre d'attentats que nous
avons à déplorer
h ouais on va vas-y un mot làdessus
après on va passer au mer ça veut dire
que quand même oui effectivement on n
parle pas et je pense que les services
ne souhaitent pas en parler parce que
faut pas aussi créer une psychose dans
le pays mais il y a énormément de de de
de de de projet d'attentat parfois assez
aboutis hein qui sont déjoués qui sont
que que la police et les service arrive
à arrive à bah justement à à briser
avant avant que le pire soit commis donc
il faut aussi s'en souvenir et le savoir
ça on va terminer sur les conséquences
politiques en France du conflit au
proche- Orient notamment à gauche
puisque c'est là que les divisions se
font le plus sentir et notamment à la
France insoumise puisque Jean-Luc
Mélenchon n' pas qualifié le Hamas
d'organisation terroriste on va écouter
Clémentine otin et Alexis corbierre qui
là-dessus ne sont pas sur la ligne de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon les écoute autant je
peux avoir un un désaccord et je pense
que c'est une faute politique de ne pas
avoir dit ce mot-là mais ils ont dit
acte de terreur mais ils ont dit acte
terroriste le seul débat maintenant il
est sur organisation terroriste vous
voyez ce que je veux dire mais vous
parlez de faute politique oui je pense
que c'est une faute politique mais c'est
pas parce que je pense que c'est une
faute politique que je supporte qu'on a
un sondage
qui qui qui qui circule on demande si
les Français sont d'accord avec la
poliition de Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui ne
condamne pas le Hamas la France
insoumise là aussi à condamner les actes
du R qu'on n vienent pas à dire tout et
n'importe quoi au nom de polémique
politicienne et certains pensent que si
on
qualifiait uniquement du mot terroriste
on ne pourrait pas par la suite
considérer comme crime de guerre les
éventuelles frappes contre des
populations civiles à gaz moi je pense
qu'on peut faire les deux pour parler
clairement il vaut mieux le dire c'est
ce que le
débatous
c'est ça nous affaiblit ça affaiblit
peut-être un peu notre parole pour dire
quoi au français que nous condamnons de
manière la plus ferme les attentats qui
ont eu lieu mais aussi la France doit
dire clairement par l'intermédi de sa
diplomatie madame Colona est là-bas au
gouvernement de netanahou folie que de
bombarder les populations à Gaza est-ce
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon là-dessus a
affaibli la France insoumise comme le
dit Alexis cor est-ce qu'il a commis une
faute comme dit ça resteah sur le
plan moral si on peut mettre de la
morale en PO
il y en a
pas oui c'est sûr de dire que Hamas
n'est pas un mouvement terroriste faut
quand même faut quand même avoir être
aveugle quoi je ve dire bon néanmoins
moi je j'attends de voir je ne sais pas
si sur un plan d'opportunisme électoral
parce que c'est un opportuniste
évidemment est-ce que c'est lui qui est
ce qu'il a tort c'est très cynique ce
que je dis mais il sait très bien ce
qu'il fait alors je veux bien qu'il y a
un caractère chez Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
s'emporte souvent très vite qui dépasse
parfois les
limites de
l'emportement peut-être que il y a ça
mais il y a quand même du calcul chez
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et il sait très bien
que les derniers les derniers scrutins
l'ont montré que son électorat il a
réussi à le capter dans les banlieux de
grandes et de petites villes un certain
électorat qui peut être sensible un
discours qui est un discours
antisioniste voire antisémite qui est un
discours proalestinien qui est un
discours pro monde arabe musulman enfin
les amalgames qu'on peut faire
habituellement et moi je ne suis pas
persué c'est c'est c'est la gauche des
minorités c'est la la gauche des
discriminations c'est plus la gauche du
tout aujourd'hui qui triomp c'est plus
si elle triomp elle ne triomphe pas
c'est cette gauche- là qui est
majoritaire me semble-t-il par rapport à
la la gauche que revendique monsieur
Roussel la la gauche laborieuse enfin la
vieille gauche quoi je suis pas je ne
sais pas je sais pas vous êtes de la
vidive alors pas tout à fait il y a
peut-être une petite dimension
électoraliste dans la position de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est possible je
crois que plus fondamentalement il y a
une stratégie de la France insoumise ou
en tout cas de Jean-Luc Mélenchon de
conflictualisation de tout et qu'on
observe depuis en particulier les
dernières élections qui se traduisent
par au au Parlement en fait une posture
parlementaire des députés de la France
insoumise qui qui exprime et même
surjoue la colère populaire faisant le
Paris que ça la canalise que lui donner
une expression tout à fait explicite en
fait ça la canalise je ne sais pas dans
quelle mesure ça la canalise ce qu'on
observe quand même dans les enquêtes
d'opinion c'est que cette posture dans
l'opinion en général elle froisse elle
bloque elle elle contrarie beaucoup de
gens elle est pour partie
contreproductive et y compris d'ailleurs
au cœur de l'électorat Jean-Luc
Mélenchon enfin souvenons-nous quand
même la Fondation gen produit pas mal
d'études là-dessus que au moment de la
présidentielle quasiment la moitié de
l'électorat de Jean-Luc Mélenchon du
premier tour 46 % de ses électeurs
considèrent que Jean-Luc Mélenchon a un
problème avec la démocratie et Queen
gros on peut voter pour lui vote utile
pour éventuellement faire barrage à
Marine Le Pen mais qu'on ne veut pas
qu'il soit président de la République
c'est que au cœur même de son électorat
il y a quand même des gens qui sont très
réticents et je ne suis pas sûr que
cette stratégie de conflictualisation là
en particulier sur cette question
extrêmement sensible du conflit
israélo-palestinien je ne suis pas sûr
qu'elle produise beaucoup de de de
résultats positif et je note dernière
chose que sur l'union de la gauche alors
effectivement toute cette séquence
fragilise la nup fragilise la dupess
parce que précisément sur l'union de la
gauche l'immense majorité des électeurs
et des sympathisants de gauche sont pour
l'Union en considérant que entre les
différentes composantes de la gauche les
points d'accord l'emportent très
largement sur les points de désaccord
les points de désaccord justement il
portent en fait sur les questions
internationales essentiellement donc ça
n'est pas un hasard si ça pète autour de
la question du conflit
israelllo-palestinien mais considérant
qu'encore une fois normalement les
questions internationales sont d'ordre
secondaire en France et que la question
sociale ou la question des égalité en
général l'emporte là-dessus là
précisément ça fragilise légitimement
l'attelage de laanupes mais comme vous
le disiez tout à l'heure en fait plus
intéressant et peut-être plus important
et peut-être plus inquiétant pour
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ça fragilise au sein
même de la France insoumise c'est rare
qu'on entende autant de leaders de la
France insoumise sortir en même temps du
bois pour dénoncer les propos de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon j'aiécouté tout à
l'heure Alexis Cambier sur votre plateau
qui disait même il ouvre quand même des
perspectives pour 2027 François Ruffin
l'a déjà fait certes mais lui-même qui
est un un ancien très très proche de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ouvre des
perspectives pour 2027 en disant
Jean-Luc Mélenchon lui-même a dit faites
mieux je vais passer le ballon prenons
donc il y aura un avant et un après
c'est ça me semble incontestable cela
dit euh moi je reste persuadé que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon reste la figure
centrale euh Ruffin qui connaît François
Ruffin qui connaît Alexis corbierre qui
connaît voyez non c'est problèm et
d'ailleurs Jean-Luc Mélenchon avait un
peu théorisé ça il y a il y a quelques
années c'était avant l'élection de de
c'est juste après d'ailleurs l'élection
de Macron à la présidence de la
République en 2018 je crois en disant
que son mouvement était gazux et
c'est-à-dire que ça ça pouvait aller un
peu dans tous les sens et c'est vrai que
ça ça ressemble un peu à ça et ça a
toujours ressemblé à ça on on continue à
parler de ces sujets c'est à la une de
la presse régionale ce
[Musique]
matin Alex à la une de la presse
régionale c'est le recueillement en
haras après l'attaque de vendredi oui
plus de 5000 personnes ont rendu hommage
hier à Dominique Bernard le professeur
assassiné dans l'attentat de vendredi
c'est à la unee de la voie du nord de la
Provence et du journal L'Union beaucoup
d'enseignants étaient rassemblés sur
cette place des Héros à haras un moment
intense qui rappelle la communion de
janvier 2015 après l'attentat de Charlie
Hebdo des larmes et de la dignité c'est
ce qu'on pouvait voir sur cette place
des Héros une ancienne chef
d'établissement réagit dans les colonnes
de la voie du Nord je la site je
m'interroge sur l'après comment les
élèves et les enseignants vont dépasser
tout ça la communauté pédagogique est
préparée rationnellement mais
émotionnellement elle ne l'est pas on a
envie de crier de hurler stop ça suffit
autre actualité aujourd'hui c'est cette
conférence sociale entre syndicat et
gouvernement oui alors c'est un
événement qui a été un peu éclipsé de la
une des journaux aujourd'hui éclipsé par
d'autres événements notamment sportifs
on va en parler dans quelques instants
Orian mais c'est bien le début de la
conférence des sociales sur les salaires
et le journal Le télégram en parle les
syndicats rencontre aujourd'hui la
première ministre ellisabeth borne avec
des attentes concrètes d'abord réformer
certaines branches professionnelles dont
le salaire minimum est toujours en
dessous du SMIC combler les inégalités
de revenus entre les femmes et les
hommes et puis défendre une contribution
des plus riches pour financer ces
mesures la patronne de la CGT Sophie
binz se félicite que la mobilisation
syndicale ait entraîné la tenue de cette
conférence sociale et vous disiez Alex
c'est le sport le rugby qui domine ce
matin les unes de la presse régionale et
oui le sport est cruel avec ce résultat
malheureux puisque le 15 de France s'est
incliné hier en hier en quart de finale
de sa coupe du monde contre l'Afrique du
Sud au Stade de France un score très
serré 28 à 29 le rêve brisé à la unee de
la Dépêche du Midi un point et c'est
tout titre Le Courrier Picard le point
final retien ce matin tellement cruel
pour la montagne rageant à la une du
Dauphiné Libéré les Bleus s'inclinent
après une première mi-temps de toute
beauté de la part des deux équipes le
retour d'Antoine Dupont après sa
fracture de la pommette n'aura pas suffi
le capitaine de l'équipe de France qui a
d'ailleurs et gratiné l'arbitre il
estime que l'arbitrage n'a pas été au
niveau de l'enjeu et puis après avoir
digéré cette frustration et bien
l'avenir est à reconstruire pour cette
génération qui avait tout misé sur cette
Coupe du monde en France sud-ouest pose
la question de l'avenir le sélectionneur
Fabien Galtier a lui assuré qu'il
continuerait sa mission son contrat va
jusqu'en 2028 et puis la moyenne d'âge
de cette équipe de France est de 27 ans
donc bon nombre d'entre eux ont des
chances de jouer la prochaine Coupe du
monde en Australie en 2027 merci Alex
sur cette note optimisme Yve la Une du
Figaro les enseignants en première ligne
face à la terreur islamiste oui alors
évidemment avec ce qui s'est passé à ras
vendredi et puis et puis le rêve brisé
des Bleus aussi c'est la photo de de Une
du Figaro ou tout ça est à lire dans Le
Figaro Mathieu souquer on remonte votre
livre 2022 la flambé populiste c'est
chez plomb merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous dans ce club merci merci Alex
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi
prochain rendez-vous à 18h sans public
avec Thomas HUG et nous on se retrouve
demain notre invité ce sera Bruno
rotillot le président du groupe les
républicains au Sénat à
demain